si je passe la parole à présent madame
caroline cayeux pour le groupe ump merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
permettez moi de vous interroger sur un
sujet qui devrait être simple mais qui
apparaît comme devenant un parcours du
combattant
je voudrais parler de la complexité des
formulaires vous venez de le sous
entendre il ya quelques instants dans la
réponse précédente je voudrais donc
parler de la complexité des formulaires
et du nombre de documents à fournir par
les prestataires des allocations
familiales
dans mon département de l'oise fin 2012
la caf avait à traiter 134 mille
dossiers allocataires elle est donc très
sollicités puisqu'elle reçoit 3 146
mille appels téléphoniques neuf cent
soixante dix sept mille plis soit 12 %
de plus que l'année 2011 est il y a à ce
jour plus de 200 mille visites des
allocataires qui veulent s'assurer de
leurs droits et de la nécessité des
documents à joindre pour une demande des
deux logements par exemple il faut
fournir au moins une dizaine de
justificatifs les allocataires qui sont
souvent en grande précarité et en grande
détresse ont non seulement du mal à
assimiler ces contraintes et pour
certains d'entre eux à comprendre les
formulaires qu'ils doivent déposer ne
pourrait-on pas envisager une meilleure
coordination des acteurs pour simplifier
le système des prestations et pourquoi
pas en fusionner certaines les
prestations sont complexes et il me
semble qu'il faudrait améliorer le
service rendu je suis consorts
consciente que la question n'est pas
simple à résoudre
puisqu'il faut maintenir aussi un
certain nombre d'outils en matière de
lutte contre les fraudes mais je crois
qu'une réforme de gestion de la gestion
des prestations familiales allégerait à
la fois les prestataires mais également
le personnel des caf et cette réforme
répondrait au voeu de tous pour une
meilleure gestion des dossiers
on a abordé il ya quelques instants la
prochaine convention d'objectifs et de
gestion qui devrait être l'occasion
d'adopter des objectifs précis et des
indicateurs de suivi j'espère que
celle-ci sera la hauteur de l'espérance
des caf et de ses allocataires madame la
ministre comptez-vous prendre des
mesures pour donner aux caisses
d'allocations familiales les moyens
d'assurer la continuité du service
public face à la demande sociale qui
explose merci mme bertinotti
madame la sénatrice effectivement la
simplification
poursuit un double objectif à la fois
faciliter les démarches des allocataires
et maîtriser la charge de travail des
caisses d'allocations familiales
cela peut prendre plusieurs formes d'une
part il faut aller vers un développement
significatif de la dématérialisation
par exemple dématérialisation de la
déclaration de grossesse et faire en
sorte qu'il n'y a plus qu'une seule
déclaration pour tous les organismes de
sécurité sociale mais aussi pour la pmi
et non pas redemander à chaque fois le
même le même papier suppression de la
fourniture d'un relevé d'identité
bancaire papier il n'y aura plus de
demandes d'attestation loyers pour les
locataires pour l'ouverture d'un droit à
l'aide au logement puisque c'est une
procédure de contrôle qui sera menée
auprès des bailleurs et à terme c'est à
dire vers la fin de l'année 2014 on
estime que l'ensemble des formalités
pourrait s'opérer par internet et on
voit déjà de nombreuses caisses
d'allocations familiales qui s'oriente
vers cette dématérialisation
systématique le deuxième axe c'est de
faciliter les démarches en renforçant
les synergies avec les partenaires
améliorer les échanges avec les services
fiscaux et les bailleurs sociaux
dématérialisation des échanges avec les
mdph pour la gestion des prestations
handicap
dématérialisation des mutations inter
régimes et dématérialisation de la
transmission caisse primaire d'assurance
maladie des demandes de couverture de
maladie universelle complémentaire
enfin le troisième axe est la
simplification des prestations
simplification du rsa nous aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir
simplification de la gestion des
allocations logement puisque il s'agit
d'opérer une modification des dates des
faits pour limiter les indus et ses
travaux ont été initiés dans le cadre du
rapport fragonard et se poursuivre merci
madame cayeux
merci madame la ministre pour ces
précisions je me permets simplement
d'ajouter que les allocataires et ceux
qui viennent dans les caisses
d'allocations familiales n'ont pas tous
internet à leur disposition et que la
dématérialisation et je dirais des
simplifications qu'ils ne comprennent
pas toujours et qu'il me paraît donc
nécessaire d'expliquer un peu mieux ce
que nous souhaitons évidemment et par
rapport aux premières questions qui ont
été posées par mes collègues s'agit pas
d'augmenter les charges financières des
caisses d'allocations familiales mais
bien de simplifier leur gestion et de
leur permettre de répondre d'une manière
peut-être plus rapide aux usagers et
plus clair pour tous ceux qui n'ont pas
à leur disposition internet aujourd'hui
et donc qui ne connaissent pas bien ses
manoeuvres merci madame ministre